[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau journal des informations locales
et nous sommes le mercredi 29 septembre
voici les titres de cette édition le
prix de l'immobilier explose dans les
Yvelines une augmentation accélérer par
la crise sanitaire l'exemple avec la
ville de Chatou dans ce journal nous
reviendrons sur le marché immobilier
yvelinois avec nos invités du jour à 10
jours des élections municipales attrape
la campagne des candidats se poursuit
après l'annulation officiel des
précédents des élections au mois d'août
Ali Rabeh se représente au scrutin à
venir le candidats de gauche organiser
un meeting samedi et puis la foire de
Chatou se poursuit jusqu'au 3 octobre au
programme brocantes et antiquités pour
700 1e édition 400 exposant se sont
donné rendez-vous sur l'île des
Impressionnistes et bijoux meubles ou
encore un vampire sont à dénicher sur
place
20 gars pour est fermée sur la ligne J
c'est ce qu'a annoncé à la CGT cheminot
menthe et Vexin elle a raison le nouveau
contrat Île-de-France mobilité voulu par
la Région une situation intolérable
selon le syndic a un reportage d'Antoine
Durand
SNCF pourrais fermer une vingtaine de
gars au 1er janvier 2021 sur la ligne J
reliant la gare de Saint-Lazare à
l'ouest parisien une information avancé
par la CGT cheminot demander Vexin en
cause un nouveau projet de la SNCF
baptisé trajectoire gare
ce projet trajectoire gars va supprimer
supprimer 20 gars d'ouverture de guichet
ces gars qui sont nommés à être fermée
vont rester ouverte bien sûr en tant que
gars mais les guichets seront fermés les
usagers n'auront plus accès à l'achat
des billets ou de renseignements ou une
information que tu as droit d'obtenir
quand il viendra un gars les gars
concerné seront située entre
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et Gisors ainsi
que celle entre Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
et Mantes-la-Jolie
autre. Qui inquiète le syndicat
cheminots
l'accessibilité pour les usagers ainsi
que leur sécurité
des personnes à mobilité réduite
les personnes âgées qui sont pas
toujours tout faire
pour reprendre la parole de
tout le monde ne rentre pas dans les
cases et en cas de situation perturbé le
jour où il y a un train qui
qui tombe en panne il se passe quelque
chose un accident de personne n'importe
quoi qui peut se passer le train et
t'arrêter en gare les gens seront livrés
hangar à personne pour les syndicats ce
projet pourrait engendrer la suppression
de 95 postes contacter la SNCF n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos sollicitations
[Musique]
maison avec jardin proche du RER à ce
genre de bien immobilier se vend à très
vite notamment à Chatou dans la ville
impressionniste les prix du marché
immobilier ont augmenté en cause de
plusieurs facteurs le reportage de Celia
garçon Go et Bixente mais rien senti
steban des appartements avec des grand
balcon ou en rez-de-jardin qui
habituellement été bien qu'on avait
qu'on avait du mal à vendre c'est devenu
un petit peu aujourd'hui les biens qui
sont les plus rechercher quoi dans la
ville de Chatou et ses alentours les
prix du marché immobilier s'envole dans
cette agence immobilière la directrice
constate une augmentation des prix au
mètre carré jusqu'à 9000 € pour les
biens d'exception
encore 15 minutes
[Musique]
centre de Paris tout en profitant dans
le cadre de vie plus élevé
l'attractivité de Chatou le RER à
Levignen sont donc désormais rare dans
une pénurie bien qu'on a beaucoup de
l'acquéreur on les voit arriver le
samedi ils font les agences autour qui
ont des très gros budget mais par contre
on a pas les bien forcément parce qu'ils
recherchent parce que parce que le
marché n'est pas le même qui apparaît
dans cette autre agence immobilière à
Chatou même constat tous les biens se
vendre très rapidement en flux tendu
c'est-à-dire prendre en train bien
même si c'est un petit peu toutes
petites surfaces ta part et jusqu'à les
demandes si on a million de million de
million sa part et tu pars sans
négociation est le type d'acquéreur a
désormais changer on a beaucoup de
jeunes couples qui arrive fictivement
principalement de Paris
Neuilly Levallois et ils savent très
bien quand Titans appartement un bel
appartement
ils vont ici avoir une très belle maison
achat tous les prix moyen des maisons
augmenter de 18 % en 5 ans est d'environ
6 % seulement pour l'année 2020
le prix de l'immobilier explose on vient
de le voir notamment dans les Yvelines
dans la vie dans ce dans ce reportage on
fait le point sur ce phénomène est sur
le marché immobilier en général dans le
département avec nos deux invités du
jour ce soir nous recevons
François-Xavier et Léon Bonsoir à vous
êtes directeur de l'agence de courtier
en prêt immobilier Crédit Foncier que
sais-tu à Versailles merci d'être avec
vous et Michel plates et Rouky aussi
avec nous vous êtes le président de la
FNAIM Grand Paris la Fédération
nationale de l'Immobilier donc on sera
tous les deux merci d'être avec moi
c'est Michel est-ce que cette
augmentation a été marqué par cette
crise sanitaire finalement
Oui-Oui augmentation est là pour le 78
déjà le prix moyen du 78 est de 4200 €
c'est ça avec une évolution annuelle
pour 2020 et 2021 le plus de 4, c'est
quand même assez important sur le
département est placé au niveau de la
demande juste derrière l'Essonne et les
Hauts-de-Seine avec Versailles qui qui
est en tête voilà je voulais les villes
les plus les plus attractives
même si les gens cherchent beaucoup plus
de verdure que dans d'autres ses
Versailles Sartrouville Poissy
Montigny-le-Bretonneux est où y voilà
Versailles pas en place une évolution du
budget si vous voulez de 5,2
%
960000 Sartrouville c'est 22 % pour une
moyenne va partir 86000 x 6 et 380000
avec une une évolution de 0,2 c'est très
très peu et Montigny-le-Bretonneux pour
498 vous avez une évolution de 13 % et
oui pour un budget moyen de
544018 pourcents c'est quand même assez
important est le prix moyen sur
Versailles des transactions est de
536000 € voilà tout ça pour vous donner
des chiffres ils sont assez important
que vous avez une progression de
93,3 pourcents dans les Yvelines donc
c'est quand même assez
intéressant les gens cherchent surtout
être préparé où il est très convoité je
donne un exemple
175 mètres carrés avec une terrasse en
plus c'est dur ça se vend 980 980000 €
voilà si vous voulez je veux pas vous
abreuver de chiffres mais il y a une
évolution dans le sens de la vie
dans le reportage précédent notamment à
Chatou les montées de 18 pourcents met
en 5 ans donc il y a pas que la crise
sanitaire finalement il y a d'autres
facteurs peut-être le manque d'eau offre
pour le nombre de demande des choses
comme ça
pour 100 des Parisiens qui sont partis
de Paris les mauvais produit sur Paris
qui sont les 6e étage les balcons les
petites surfaces rez-de-chaussée façon
ils sont partis vers la première la
première ceinture vers la deuxième voilà
et la deuxième peau plus loin d'autres
qui ont cherché que dégage alors le
télétravail une
nouvelle forme de
façon de travailler qui a eu un effet
extraordinaire c'est tout ça là tu veux
bien bien entendu puis là il y a un
petit retour en arrière je parle du
télétravail dans les gens malgré tu
cherches aujourd'hui ils ont eu peur le
colis de récidive j'espère que
les balcons et terrasses Les Jardins à
partir du moment où il y a du transport
ben c'est très convoité automatique et
le 78 très convoité pour ça
est-ce que vous vous avez vu une
évolution en terme de crédit immobilier
sur
les
6 ans que les deux sont très bas mais
donc là on est déjà en septembre encore
une baisse de taux donc forcément que ça
a un impact sur joint à ce que disait
votre avis tu es sérieux ça ça va jouer
sur l'offre et la demande et donc ça va
être plus fort que la fin donc ça
forcément avoir un impact sur les jeux
sur la survivante
finalement donc est-ce que c'est un peu
aussi sur les prix que ça fait gonfler
les prix finalement derrière
terre aujourd'hui de l'évolution du prix
de Billet se
demander donc si on a une capacité de
financement plus importante et donc on
peut accéder plus facilement crédit ça
va forcément impacter le à la hausse ça
va avoir un impact sur la hausse de
l'Union
dans la grande couronne
à cause
de
moi
François-Xavier Léon pardon en terme de
démarche est-ce que les conditions
finalement d'accès au prêt immobilier
sont devenu plus exigeante
aujourd'hui il faut mieux préparer son
dossier
il y a eu un serment des conditions
d'octroi des crédits notamment la
stabilité financière
qui a fait des préconisations ont été
largement suivi par les banques assez
rapidement
et qui devient obligatoire en 1er
janvier mais on a déjà tout
et donc oui ça il y a des conditions
d'octroi qui sont un peu plus
et elle le met vraiment en application
sur ça s'est calmé dans l'application et
surtout il faut pas dépasser 35 % sur la
durée des Prés il faut pas dépasser 25
ans voir 27 ans ici dans le 9 et qui a
une période de construction
pour autant il y a des conditions qui
sont
terminés est-ce que vous vous avez
remarquer une augmentation du nombre de
personnes qui font appel à vos services
[Musique]
et
François-Xavier de
président de la
Fédération nationale de l'Immobilier
merci beaucoup à tous les deux
[Musique]
la ville de Trappes en pleine campagne
en vue des élections municipales des 10
et 17 octobre prochain merde est situé
candidats
élections à lire AB organiser un
déjeuner meeting ce samedi 25 septembre
dernier avec ses soutiens un reportage
de Celia garçon beau et Bixente mais
rien senti steban
Ali Rabeh est en campagne avec sa liste
pour que tu rates respire parmi ces
actions des rencontres avec les
Trappistes pour discuter de son
programme et de leurs attentes ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est pour les
jeunes et lui il est il travaille pour
ça les trucs pour les handicapés et n'a
rien du tout pour les handicapés à
Trappes ce sont les mêmes le logement la
sécurité l'emploi les personnes âgées
l'éducation des enfants qui est vraiment
au cœur de la vie des habitants des
32000 habitants de la ville de Trappes
et sur lesquels nous avons beaucoup de
progrès à réaliser la ville de Trappes
as parfois été mobile lors des mandats
précédent il faut mettre en faire preuve
de volontarisme et mettre énormément
d'énergie pour moderniser cette ville et
lui donner les mêmes droits que toutes
les autres comme axes prioritaires du
candidats de gauche le logement ici à
Trappes nous avons beaucoup de logement
de logements sociaux qui sont parfois
mal entretenu par les propriétaires par
les bailleurs sociaux et compris et donc
nous nous battons ou côté des habitants
des amical de locataire qui se constitue
pour faire respecter le droit des
habitants c'est un peu le pot de terre
contre le pot de terre et le rôle de la
mairie c'est de venir soutenir et
renforcer les locataires ensuite on leur
droit et en obtenant des bailleurs que
nous avons déjà réussi à obtenir pendant
l'année écoulée des investissements pour
rattraper le retard à l'érable y aura pu
profiter également de cette matinée pour
dresser un bilan d'une année passée en
tant que maire de la commune avant
l'annulation du scrutin on a mis en
œuvre a énormément de choses sur
l'éducation avec le retour du soutien
scolaire le retour des activités
périscolaires de qualité l'union de
gauche comme un Ali Rabeh aura comme
principal adversaire l'alliance entre
Othman nasrou dit Malandain et Mustapha
Larbaoui au scrutin des 10 et 17 octobre
prochain
et hier en éco au match de Ligue des
Champions PSG - Manchester City ou
l'équipe Francilienne s'est imposé 2 à 0
la marque Adidas à lancer une opération
de communication autour de Lionel Messi
plus de 2000 balles ont été distribués
en région parisienne notamment à Trappes
dans les Yvelines ils ont été dédicacé
par la star Argentine nouvel attaquant
en du Paris-Saint-Germain objectif
valoriser la pratique sportive
votre ville et elle marche Ablo début du
mois de septembre plusieurs associations
publier leur premier baromètre des
villes les plus marche able du pays 200
villes étudier certaines tu iras leur
épingle du jeu dont tu es comme une île
viennoise Mélanie Fauquet et vous êtes
avec nous ce soir bonsoir bonsoir des
journalistes pour tes 78 ans déjà est-ce
que pour nous expliquer qu'est-ce qu'une
Wilmar Châble alors pour identifier ses
fameuses ville le collectif place aux
piétons en partenariat que la dame a
proposé pendant 3 mois en français de
remplir une grille pour recueillir leurs
ressentis près de 200 villes ont été
évalué plus de 43 miles questionnaire
rempli entièrement ça c'est pour le
point de départ les questions maintenant
il y avait 5 thématique le ressenti du
quotidien du piéton la facilité ou non
de se déplacer la relation avec les
autres usagers le sentiment de sécurité
le confort de marches son avis sur
l'importance donné au déplacement à pied
est sur les aménagements et les
équipements et pour chaque question une
note de 1 à 6
est le résultat de notre sur 20 pour
chat critères et pour le ressenti global
c'est la commune donc d'Acigné qui
obtient finalement la meilleure note
mais il y a aussi et des villes qui se
sont classés la meilleure note pour
Magny-les-Hameaux à la commune de 9000
habitants se voit attribuer un 14 sur 20
et 1 à la quatrième place du classement
national toujours dans les 10 premières
avec Guyancourt avec 13,38 / 20 nous
avons demandé à quelques habitants ce
qu'ils ont pensé
je trouve que les infrastructures
piétonne sont sont très bien fait on
n'est jamais dérangé non non c'est très
bien il y a une séparation entre les
vélos les piétons et les voitures donc
on est vraiment protéger en tant qu' il
y a pas de souci puisque il y a toujours
une année pour les piétons et une année
pour les cyclistes moi je sais pas j'ai
pas de souci c'est la commune où je
trouver les voie piétonne les plus
on va dire les plus d'énergie possible
et qui occupe quasiment presque tous les
quartiers alors parmi les autres bon
élève on retrouve Montigny-le-Bretonneux
Aubergenville l'Étang-la-Ville et
Versailles Maisons-Laffitte obtient tout
juste la moyenne et ce baromètre à
vocation à être reconnu à être reconduit
tous les deux ans merci beaucoup Mélanie
Poké d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et
journaliste pour TV 78 du 24 septembre
au 3 octobre soutient la plus importante
foire à la brocante et aux antiquités de
France la foire de Chatou + 2,400
exposant se sont réunis cette année sur
l'île des Impressionnistes près de Rueil
Malmaison pour fêter la 101e édition
regarder
bijoux meuble ancien porcelaine ou
encore arme d'Empire à la foire de
Chatou antiquaire et amateur se côtoient
dans un lieu où le temps semble suspendu
depuis toujours la foire de Chatou est
marqué par la diversité des bébés
produit des œuvre des pièces présentées
Maussane est composé de
période totalement différente ça peut
aller du 18e même 17e j'ai les pièces du
7e jusqu'au 20e on est venu aujourd'hui
pour pour voir les différents exposants
et et pouvoir retrouver des des choses
dans ton tout à fait pour signer un
petit peu tout simplement
dans une ambiance familiale cette année
on est encore plus porté sur la qualité
des pièces proposés chaque édition
présenter des objets de qualité d'avoir
un expert sur place même deux experts
les experts généraliste un expert en
bijoux on veut offrir un produit top
tous nos produits tous nos meubles sont
restaurés son nettoyer son propre marche
fonctionne ici une vie normale reprends
pour les professionnels heureux
d'oublier entend la pandémie qui les a
prises et d'activités de longs mois
finalement
les gens se sont réapproprier leur
intérieur forcément puisque ils ont été
resté bloqué chez eux et du coup ils ont
profité et en fait depuis mais l'année
dernière on n'a jamais autant de travail
et c'est une véritable renaissance que
d'être aujourd'hui à Chatou la chaleur
et la convivialité des professionnels
restera toujours de mise et on vous
attend tous les jours à partir de 10h si
vous soyez à la recherche de la perle
rare ou que vous souhaitiez simplement
être surpris la foire de Chatou vous
attends jusqu'au 3 octobre
un reportage de deux Julien Leroy avec
Céline charles et pour vous rendre aux
événements yvelinois peut-être
aurez-vous besoin de prendre le train et
pourquoi pas le train Paris - Musée et
met en service ce mardi 28 septembre ce
train circulant sur la ligne du RER C
permis de redécouvrir deux célèbres
reproduction des œuvre des musées
parisiens est celle du palais Galliera
du Petit Palais du musée d'art moderne
encore du musée avec carnaval et
l'intérieur des quatre voiture a été
transformé à l'aide d'un film plastique
une opération qui a nécessité quand même
un travail de 600 heures et la présence
de 7 Professionnel un partenariat entre
Paris Musée Transilien SNCF et
Île-de-France mobilité
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver Mélanie poquet à la
présentation de votre magazine société
très bonne soirée à tous sur Télé 78
[Musique]